hi this is Mike my Hardy and Snorlax
charity drive here for resident knievel
I asked you if you changed my name and
you said no this was like two hours ago
when I set up before you got here it's
Marrakech
we've been gone for like two weeks what
was it - what
it gave me three different things yeah I
just typed three separate words one
thing yeah we what was it last week you
flew to Ohio Friday but also I had a
crazy deadline Thursday for her it was a
bad week I had a baby shower my sister
was having a baby whelp she's going to
have a baby and I wanted to be there for
her so I went to I went to Ohio to see
her and you were busy
like I mean Red Dead Assassin's Creed
Odyssey Soul Calibur it was a lot going
on a priority it is it's super priority
but I also think like I got over a
migraine the other day you were sick or
something I got sick yesterday but I'm
fine
I it it's hard to explain yeah anyway
I'm not even sick it's like one of those
things where bodies suck well we I I
mean I did my research I know I mean we
need to do just so we're back I don't
know and I so I do have this thingy
which I'm think I can use yeah but you
don't actually need you want me to do
something first it's what people keep
matching we need to go get this specific
chemical we'll need for a team so let me
ask you this then mm-hmm I'm here should
I leave some stuff in here cuz both of
my peeps are super full um so if I'm
gonna go get like you're only going back
for one thing but if you want to leave
open slots in case you find something
what I'm saying is I'm gonna come back
to this area that's not yeah you can
leave the hookshot so I can leave the
hookshot here okay that's what I want
you want to go back to the mansion or
whatever it was we came from okay and
then I also have well that's my only
question I guess
yeah because I want him to keep his
shotgun and I want him to keep his gun I
should come Bend these come on meri has
been a while I'm even you could probably
drop that one bullet well I was gonna
say or give to I'm gonna give it to her
exchange wait that didn't go well
okay good all right cool up so now they
both have a couple slots now they're not
very healthy that's something to
remember here yes first night it's
Breanna right and she has a full heal no
I did not no you didn't I did not so
that's why people were telling us to
make sure we got it before we come here
because now we have to fight a few
monkeys oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
well you have your shotgun right his
shotgun yeah I'll figure it out if
you'll just maybe I did do it one of
those spoiler runs that you do at the
end of episode this is our that was the
hook shot that got it
this is our punishment for like not
paying attention is it right here buggy
I do that every time I walk into a room
I missed this show not you Billy
Rebecca you haven't changed at all
I missed you Mary you did not I did
don't believe you
fine what's your fault I wait monkeys
monkey no wait was that Oh magnum rounds
you guys oh yes I dropped my Magnum
condoms for my no he does these is it
wrong
monster condoms for my Mac yeah yeah
should I get a malt off no well what's
in your inventory I have three slots
full for total he she's got three I'd
say he's got four I heard if she fill
the slot alright
she filled it no we're done
see that I stopped something immediately
stop that runaway train
get back here train you get back here
right now monkeys should I stop her from
shooting they're so quiet yeah I think
you got him what's that two of them two
or one no god they're so vicious ooh
look three plants though - I can count
those plants are good should I have her
pick one of those up - yeah that could
help
I feel like plants are a big deal
considering we're both on coffee home
I'm gonna need you to guide me a little
bit yeah can you pull up you about yes
first of all this door okay yes that's
the only door remember it end results so
I think it's the room next to the chest
the giant chessboard if we can't
remember which one that was I think wait
okay right we'll get in here first yet
are you following me
Hey
get over here monkey no monkey
the monkey check I think the chess room
is the top-left one I could be the one
I'm right next to right now easily be
wrong but yes I think so I think you're
right but I you want to be infirmary
which is next to the chess room I mean
we'll find out right now Bucky buck I
hear you I hear you monkey
I hear you yeah God oh [ __ ]
she's hurt here you they died so I think
I'm hurt they're both on orange caution
I can heal both of them fully right now
well it's principle I'd say wait really
yeah because if you go to the chest room
there's nothing there there's no I mean
I think you might be near enough to it
that you're not even to fight anymore
it could be wrong I mean you wait which
is the Chester those one to your left
right now I don't know maybe down the
hall I think that's it but that would
mean the infirmary is the one at the end
of the hall so we want to go in the
infirmary the one at the end of the hall
yeah so door this one yeah got it
actually you switch I'd rather have the
shotgun oh [ __ ] two monks
monkey
so do these monkeys just randomly show
up now in this part of the base I think
because I'm gonna do a lot of blown-up
not like randomly okay
this totally this is where we missed
something
well there's that capsule thing I think
capsule gonna get Rebecca and go to that
thing was that noise was that me was
that you one of us made a noise this
thing yeah yeah so the whole reason that
we couldn't do that last time is we
literally examine it with Billy so
that's what we needed we're good
wait did I do it pretty sure yeah you
put it in the mixing set you can just
check it again if you want to well I
just don't understand what I did yeah I
did this say yes you already have okay
cool you have done that okay good no no
I did it just now oh yeah so when I just
did it again that you combine that with
something to make a stripping agent
later which will allow you to access a
key which you'll need oh okay and I
think the people just we should have
done it before because we would have had
to fight I remember people talking about
that but you still did pretty green
chemical is this episodes no this
season's fire fire extinguishers are in
it we never got but I got it should I
get this blue plant or do you think
we're good I'm coming back this way cool
didn't take up a slot and then there's
another green herb when we go back so
I'm going back exactly where we came
right yes okay is there a chance of
monkeys I don't know already cool
they're not like a nemesis they should
be able to like spawn do any me see a
nervous so doesn't it this is gonna be
monkeys everywhere right I'm always
fearing that every day
that's why every time you go into a room
you got to say no much buggy no monkeys
no monkeys no monkeys monkeys monkeys
wow it's a tongue twister monkeys I
think you're saying it sounds like
you're saying no monkeys monkey no mo
hey Yong ki no mo what's that noise the
leaves just the trees wait what's the
name and the episode where creamer goes
to Los Angeles and then there's that
murder taking place she's like were
there any witnesses just the trees
Johnny okay so should I drop anything
off or should I just stay super full
here so we're both super we won I think
you could drive okay I'll talk to maybe
I mean I like having them because if I
do come across some of those jerks now
he's got a full heel he doesn't need
this green herb right yeah but it'd
probably be good to have in the save
room can you do you have any more room
to save room to drop stuff oh yeah just
do that why are we going are we going
back to the same room yeah that's where
you drop the hookshot isn't it right and
that's closer to where you're going
anyway so you might as well just spread
stuff out no monkeys no monkeys no
monkeys the monkeys okey no mo I brought
cheese and cookies
I have to be on monkey alert you can't
just be talking whenever you want to
essentially my job on this show
the monkey alert is a high read it's
full fur yeah it's uncle no mo no I want
to talk to you I don't like them it's a
person it's our uncle monkeys he birthed
you yes that would be your dad
monkey no mo have you thought this
through I think everything through a
very deep thinker what it's a big black
bar in between us and the game it's not
really a big deal that didn't make it
better oh yeah it's are things that are
it's alright shouldn't I got this no
shouldn't have brought this up don't
worry I got this
you should not have even brought this up
to you put me normal please I'm trying
so you're done and then move it to the
left there you go whoo I can fix both oh
yes you guys that's better
it's I mean continue with
why does it keep doing that because when
you shrink it like that it sounds you
want to top it it's a frame got it
Stilton I mean it is it's good you did a
great job all right sorry I need to pay
attention okay so now she has enough
room for hooky there we go now can oh
she can only go up there right if it's
like the other one yeah but I think so
cuz the hookshot is - yeah I'm pretty
sure you have like an elevator thing you
can use and if she's too if he's too fat
I just let make sure she has everything
she needs to not die up there because I
don't want to die anyone wonder if she
shouldn't be this shot what am I getting
into I don't know I'm just saying like I
know it's gonna be like an elevator
thing a dumbwaiter you can use the
transport stair
if there's monkeys up there I'm gonna be
pissed you won't be separated for long
okay
and he's safe down there I assume let's
hope oh yeah he's a cool angle Dark
Souls boss arena it does look like a
Dark Souls esque style but with more
dukes which is always my biggest
criticism of the series they added them
to Dark Souls on switch a Duke boss come
here big boy
yeah this giant pair of dukes that's
like a there's characters in mouth nice
banjo tooie that are useful [ __ ] I
[ __ ] up
what do you what do you see I'm gonna
press that switch this is this is always
the dumbwaiter no no that's just like I
think this let's Billy come up there but
it says don't touch but fire what the
[ __ ] does that mean do don't touch but
fire I would never why would you ever
touch that who translated this game I
don't know don't touch but fire but why
what fire
oh I know where I am cool I remember
walking down here once back in the day
don't touch me but fire can't find a
localization team right now
can you Google don't touch but fire like
was why no monkeys has anyone else
noticed the bizarre choice of warning
signs and res equals zero HD remaster
warning underground cable before digging
trenching or pushing pipe in this
vicinity pushing pipe in this vicinity
please call repair service no charge
Bell Telephone system we've all been
there you can see a set of stairs
leading a touch pot fire
they've been collapsed and can't be used
emergency dale 9-1-1 i spelled
misspelled elevator to where am i am i
safe I feel very safe
well would you that door sound effect
mm-hmm that's a nice door no monkeys no
monkey somebody's
this isn't a strange place oh wait no
hold on what what you wanna did you come
down the elevator
yeah go back up you want to regroup with
them up there with who with my buddy how
does he get up there he can't get up
there oh yeah she can yeah this is where
you're gonna go but you want Billy I
want Billy and her I just don't
there was a gate next to that red or
that rate and I unlocked it so that's
the one Billy comes through I just don't
know so I should switch people and have
him leave and go around yeah okay I can
do that I hope she's safe out here I
feel like she is yeah I think if
something was gonna attack you a lot of
hot probably yeah okay so he's so I'm
gonna keep her by this red herb okay so
wait so he's I don't it's that way then
wherever he is yeah well I see where she
is she's here in the corner oh so he
leaves and goes outside gotcha so it's
pretty easy
I think he has a slot for that red herb
or I could just get it later I guess no
he doesn't have a slot they're both full
what do you think I could just leave it
there you just know can't you just pick
it up and combine it with a green while
you're picking it up oh I don't know
honestly I didn't know if he could do
she could do that I've all right she
would have to do it she would do it yeah
I saw people in the comments mentioning
that I still feel like I should get I
should heal them I'm a little nervous I
mean I just feel like they're both on
Orange caution okay that works for me
nothing to do here said last week on the
comment said yeah I forgot res new
bikini was today best surprise ever
honestly this alone makes my day thank
you Mike and Lipton for the best sorry
video damn it Lipton
wow there's Lipton Gilgamesh person
looks just like Mary Kay god damn it
everyone have their labs no grab the
thingy J heard he tried MS charity drive
to you alright they're together now to
the lab okay so now we're going okay now
I always feel super good after I fully
heal my character I just feel like
untouchable debora monkeys monkeys
monkeys monkeys don't there's so they're
so bouncy you know like you never know
if they're gonna be coming up from above
or below like that's what I don't like
about them just looks like blood on the
floor you see this I feel a little
nervous what's that noise pulling down
the stairs alright so there's a save
room to the right and some rebounds
oh cool well an elevator shoot for
transporting items it appears to be
connected to the operating room send
something to the operating room hmm
I don't really know what to do with it
so I'm not going to but this appears to
be the same type of puzzle we had
earlier on the train so I'm gonna pick
these up but then not take them unless
you think I should save right now
yeah save I think that would you're not
gonna lose saving
I mean I'll save up I'll lose a puck
boy fully healed Anna save I dead grass
this is not the right word this is the
safest that I feel fully healed and
fully saved I am like on top of the
world it's such a nice feeling I love it
I like it more when you're quakin mm-hmm
remember the bats yeah never again oh
that's a Marcus's diary did die close my
babies in a special capsule
to open the capsule special stripping
agent I have that collectible plate is
that a dead guy is a dead guy
is this another this is another hook
shot isn't it is that what that is
or is that just a fancy yeah probably
Billy can use the hook shot he can it
was it wasn't the hook shot that
couldn't support his weight on the train
it was the actual thing you were at
latching on to all right so should I
finish these doors before I use this
hook shot or should I do the hook shot
first and then the don't use those doors
oh that's the one you came through oh
you're right because they're red yeah so
I can't use them so should Billy go up
there he's only got okay you need them
all tops oh Lord
yeah just give him the hook give her
that second handgun he doesn't need that
well I can oh [ __ ] I did it again I'm up
day but yeah hi no I god bless it so
hard to convince so you're saying don't
take the gun guns are good well you need
the molotovs and neither shotgun in the
shelves why do I need the shelves just
extra shells I don't know just because
so he's safer with it I mean you don't
need it if you'd rather do the hang on
instead of reloading the shotgun I don't
know it depends on what I'm fighting you
want them all tops all right well I know
what that means
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's so complicated uh yeah and he's got
no health on him well he me no likey but
he's got a soul he'll he's got a full
heal and he's a strong boy electro
Cucamonga table for
oh my god wait small tops get out he's
right in front of you shut the [ __ ] up
inch forward
are you maybe this is the wrong room
hold on keep in check know this
stressful pretty sure he's here
so somewhere oh my god I'm gonna read
this note dick diary today I changed the
code I asked him what the code was and
he was like based on my child's growth
something significant his children's
growth but he doesn't have children
it's his babe the test-tube babies did
you see these pills dude was taking some
pills Oh God God God God you've done
this to me keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going not run
never run not run yes is he dead I think
so but get ready to throw if not oh I'm
ready this is my ready to throw stance
got look forward to the lawsuits when
from people's burst eardrums I got a
look we have a look we have a Knievel
her lawyer entertainer don't worry Tina
that's me I'm a terrible lawyer also a
doctor of pharmacology no I'm not and
I'm also a gap Snorlax charity drive ah
did you read that previous thing that
said press this button to blow up no I
was kidding your brother okay wait I
can't take this if it gives me one I
don't have any room yeah you need that
I'm Supes full oh yeah you have one more
and where does it go yeah cuz you have
one more Molotov right you can probably
just leave the Molotov here or how do
you get back down you just jump through
the hole oh wait I don't know there's
like another room to the right and
everything and I'm full I'd say just
drop the Molotov I don't think you'll
need that for now but there's also a gas
container and wine in here which means I
make more moles I think those were there
just there in case you didn't already
have them I mean you're I'm not saying
there's nothing to worry about the few
I'm just saying like can i slide down
here you try em
I mean yeah you might as well just drop
some things together right but like what
if there's one of those guys in here or
like in the next room come back here and
make more [ __ ] the camera angles get me
every time so there's I'm I'm just gonna
be aware that it exists because you know
sometimes I forget that there's items I
assume I need this right now is that
what you're saying I mean that's what
you came up here for
can you quick a shotgun before you
forget anything I don't know what's this
hallway honestly it's that's a bit no
monkey no monkey ooh there's a button
yeah I'll say let's just get a layout of
the land
oh really [ __ ] am I where's that another
savers at the library to the north no I
have I ever been here before cuz like
why are those items blinken's no wait
that's where I came from I'm dumb what's
the name of this floor you're on b1 okay
no I've never been here before
cuz these are all gray so cool I hit
that switch a flick of the switch
oh my [ __ ] god we what just happened
I don't know is that gonna attack
Rebecca no no is it gonna rataxes
[Music]
well [ __ ] is it what did you just do
you're a guide I know he's you're fine
you won't encounter him yet then why is
the music stressful I don't know it's a
mess with you
[Music]
dude go see that's our story the next
door you can go no you best when you
came I know but I should have a motive
should I not
no don't worry I can drop the hook shot
and make mall tops right now okay and
this isn't even this isn't even like a
discussion like I'm going to do it can't
have music like that and have me not
super prepared
right pick that one up to like 100
I feel better now I think he's in this
room and he's in this hallway know you
he was he's below you cuz this thing
raised up so he's below you may open
your mouth like that noise go through
that door to the north
am i right yeah in this room but he's
not able to get to you right now cuz you
raised that thing and let him out is my
girlfriend okay
[Music]
I'm gonna check on her yeah she's her
room is totally separate you can open up
math you wanna see where she has
relation is he in the hallway yeah he's
in the next room yeah all right you stay
right there baby girl oh man more [ __ ]
yeah boo bucks oh please
sorry I mean it well that's great cuz I
just also remember you have that thing
that you can transport items with what
you have that dumbwaiter oh yeah it's in
there it must be you could send her you
should probably wanna send her the
molotov stuff what if I sent her the gun
well she wants the molotovs definitely
because she's no she's the one with him
yeah I understand
got too much yeah I think we forgot
about the dumbwaiter and that confused
us but that's gonna be pretty crucial
yeah I think it's in there okay let me
just make these real fast because I'm
here all right so wait you can still
make some more oh you only have one
space no no no I already made these
these are our already mall tops
that's for maltose and then I have three
but I'm not gonna send her seven so I
was gonna like keep four and sent her
three [ __ ] maybe it's somewhere else
down or just not even in this room
there's another doorway in the hall
there's a little walkway your left oh
yeah I see that a ladder okay sweet all
right well we're getting somewhere so
let's go into the other room that was in
this hallway that should have the yellow
I mean I hope so I'm we're yeah we're
back in stressful song town
[Music]
awful it's like the sound of music but
kinky no something no monkeys dumbwaiter
IQ tango me like Harry at the spy
remember that [ __ ] I do actually
that is such a cool scene if I may say I
grew up watching Harriet the Spy so much
oh that my parents called me Mary at the
spy and I I'm not kidding I had a
shotgun shells
I had a raincoat and and a notebook and
I used to write down all sorts of stuff
in it cuz I was telling my mariette
story
oh here we go hold on stop it for
leeches for wait go back
I'm reading backwards administrated t
into for leeches their will to survive
leads them to parasitism and predation
then they breed and they multiply seven
days since administration of T rapid
growth and double former size signs of
transformation emerging spawning
successful hold on go back sorry
well four is set for first four leeches
right down for leeches seven days into
it they double their numbers so that's
eight okay after seven days just be
clear in there's now eight in one hour
but they're ravenous appetites lead them
to cannibalism hastened to increase food
supply but lost too
so now we have seats provided them with
live feed but lost half when the live
food fought back so I have lost half
however the leeches are learning from
experience and are beginning to exhibit
group attack behavior they are also
ceasing cannibalism their evolution is
exceeding expectations leech is no
longer exhibited individual behavior
even when not feeding they move as a
elective they consume everything I offer
with remarkable efficiency an employee
has stumbled onto my experience
experiment scan a human be a food source
Oh God
a day worth commemoration they're
mimicking me they recognize their pop
pop wonderful children okay so I think
that's correct
cool [ __ ] that guy scared the [ __ ] out
of me did I lose health from that no
good everything looks well used do you
think do you think that guys alive we
going can you go through between those
desks I don't think there's much more
for me to do you want me to touch those
ooh this looks like something for the
lady she's got the chemical contains
it's full of poisonous gas wait no you
have oh yeah you're right sorry I
thought the lady I thought the girl had
to do this let me get a little closer
okay no it's telling me no but I think
we're on the right track here it appears
to be a device for pumping gas no it's a
device is empty just go through those
double doors
you mean what doesn't oh yeah those
these are cool doors if you like we
talked about a lot about doors in this
series what is that what is that she's
regular zombies I think zombies don't
sound like that do they
I should have worked my gun
suck shell [ __ ] I should have backed up
I thought I had him that's gonna give me
a little mark is he dead I think so
that's weird I knew it [ __ ] it is he
dead
oh for [ __ ]
what a game we play oh my god there's
blood everywhere and I'm like running
out of shells here no I'm okay son so
send Rebecca the capsule and the
molotovs for sure
right now yeah cuz there's other stuff
up here but you might as well offload
that so I think he can get some like
healing stuff that makes sense
okay so okay it's heading something to
the Reference Room so the malt hops
funny if they got down there and they
were lit on fire
Starlin character have you watched um
the haunting of Hill House no it's a
show on Netflix Netflix and it also has
a dumbwaiter in a but in the spoopy way
is it good um so far it is so the thing
about spoopy movies that I feel like you
have to explain is that sometimes
they're good but then at the end they
like you know they're like it was the it
was the Beagle the whole time and it's
like come on you know what I mean
so it's so far it's really good but I
don't know how it ends and I don't know
what the thing is or any of the things
they're going on like they even
explained it so it could be good because
so far it's really good it's about a
house that's there's people in it and
they're getting haunted and stuff it's a
bit slow it's kind of like a slow burn
okay so now I'm gonna switch peeps back
to him and he's gonna offload more items
he's going to offload this chemical
thing is that what you said yes
now she can't come up right well can she
now because she can get through that
room is that the case is that what
you're telling me
what are you telling me now she's got
this thing and she's still safe and now
he's got some free spots so I'm gonna be
him again and now I could investigate
this area there's some other things in
the other room - right yes I was running
out of space but I mean shouldn't I
investigate now yeah yeah with my little
think there's feeling stuff in here
I hope there's no more so I gave her
them my mall table so I don't have any
multi on me it's just something to be
weary aware of first dates right I see
it looks like somebody's been ransacking
these places looking for stuff showdown
what's this this is a door it is a door
I'm gonna go through that later huh more
chemical goo dr. Marcus blah blah blah
disappeared
[Music]
progenitor hideous no five
experimentation using employees as
guinea pigs all right I feel like we get
the gist of it
it's like lore all right and so I'm
gonna go through this room now yeah okay
oh [ __ ]
oh wait no that's that's you need
Rebecca but okay
I think you could just switch to her
right now yeah yeah I guess he's done
for now Hey right he's not safe he's not
safe I was getting oh Jesus he's safe I
was kidding
Duke knew that just kidding I don't like
you should get all his stuff
yes so she's got three motives - hey
guys - hanga she's like Lara Croft you
shouldn't need more than two three
months you won't need more than three
miles Hobbes you might not need more
than two so you should just go toss him
at that leech dude who's in the hallway
all right I'm gonna switch equip ease
and he's
what so he's here he's in here all right
I don't know where he is we'll find out
he's a floor up or down
he's a floor up but either way I have to
go through here there's something in the
hallway you don't want her to die
is he in here [ __ ] where is it I found
it
he's mutated yeah get some distance
heal heal heal heal I can't [ __ ] off
kill now I mean orange cautions pretty
bad I mean it's better than what I
thought it would be he's dead
that sucks max any Rebecca okay so on my
okay now thank God I had three said yeah
get that thing I already have it yeah no
no yes Adam
that'll make some stripping agent now
use that on the bleach canister okay and
then that'll give you the key you send
that up to Billy
don't just go to the kit and I think you
use the kit okay oh oh wait no I
understand
that's not her kit it's alright stop it
let's don't it sorry
switch yeah okay I don't use okay
combined send that damn the
gross-looking key those doors are both
locked so just get her to sit was it in
here yeah uh-huh
nothing was awful mm-hmm
excuse me
green-tea went down the wrong tube
that's not what I meant to do every time
all right so oh god I didn't mean to do
that that was an accident I was not
paying attention get back in there we
can get progress yeah I think so too
all right dial each arm
yes hiccup
um okay what do I do with it oh it's one
update yeah now before I do this I do
have a free spot should she send me up a
gun um you should go back down to her
anyway because I think we missed
something in that hallway I can't go
back down to her
sorry switch to her uh-huh
and then there's a herb in the hallway I
think we missed okay but to your point
in what hallway Oh in the hallway with
the evil guy pass the tank hopefully
there's no more because I don't have any
more mall tabs here
sucked that's great
what did that just unlock did you use
the leech at the leech okay though beach
key no I did not I think that might
unlock something down here well I mean
right here is a bust with a leach key
right here you need to see it oh maybe
that goes down oh [ __ ] sorry
it's okay I mean that goes down here how
do you know that I don't there's a blue
one and a green one this is this look
more blue yeah this looks blue the one
upstairs green I don't know I don't know
yeah I think you might I think I might
have jumped the gun on that okay okay
it's a very small gun it's not like
you're jumping over like you know a
bunch of aks this joke has run its
course it's like a little like one of
those guns at the garage it from boom in
a black girls in like the Westerner is
these two have little patience when it
comes out your wrist and then you
[ __ ] not kidding shoot him
okay so I'm gonna have him send it back
that's the plan
wait while he's here just the double
check here Bella green green to me that
looks very green and now this looks a
bit turquoise but I would say it says
blue each charm that's by its these
charges
go on this trains to going too far
all right well I'm a curly-headed [ __ ]
alright so I'm switching back she's
gonna get it she's gonna get this thingy
okay so again though if there's like
dangerous [ __ ] behind that door I'm not
ready or prepared whose fault is that I
yours you're the guide what kind of
stuff are you expecting behind the door
I don't know one of those guys that
requires a Malta
I mean you'll need you should heal no no
no no it won't be one of the guys that
requires a Molotov but there will be
guys I think I only have two guns and
yes money that's worth healing I'm on
orange caution should I you know what's
the more powerful use you're more
powerful handgun right oh you're right
this one isn't it thank ya it's got a
scope so it's got a scope it's more
likely to get criticals and then yeah
you should heal yeah you think I should
fully heal yeah you're right orange how
you're gonna use the gun to heal how
does it work it's like an inhaler but
your mouth on it oh my god all right
Marcus looks busty there this is we're
gonna lose so many subs today yeah right
this is the day can he was like the best
subs they should make a knievel sub
sandwich
oh god there's so much stuff in this
room that makes me uncomfortable a fan
the fishtank there's like a skull on the
left there woman in love with a dead man
like there's nothing good about this
place what is that I don't think I have
room for this I did yeah
I do not have a room for this
James to commemorate your graduation
1939 what those Dukes
great dummy what was the point of that
[ __ ] cutscene college roommate
mysterious objects are floating in the
water his history teacher oh please I
don't know if I I do have room for you
there's a door at the back of the study
you should go through songs a record
player I don't know it's very yes it's a
record play and then this looks like a
box that I should take but I know it's
like a desktop thing no this no it's
like a pen case come on in cigar box
I'd be looting the [ __ ] out of these
houses it's like probably filled with
like stuff that's made out of real gold
and copper
I'd be like stripping the wires at this
place mm-hmm [ __ ]
what I'd know that other guys gonna come
up is there another guy in here right
next to you oh that least that other
ones dead thank God nice amazing
that guns pretty good I did not do a
great job and I took no damage his
picture is composed of four separate
sheets there doesn't seem to be anything
special about it aside from the fact
that it's composed of four separate
pieces it's pretty [ __ ] cool is it
the Last Supper it is yeah that's Jesus
I recognized Jesus when I see him one
guy in there is it theirs Barnabas nice
King Peter Gary James John Luke I know I
know some apostle very this Judas is in
there son of a [ __ ] how come nobody
names their kid Judas anymore I don't
know I'm gonna name my firstborn and it
there's a Benedict you know about Oh
Cumberbatch yeah why's there no Judas
Cumberbatch he's like the lesser-known
actor son and he's always mad about it
cuz he got he got the name Judas hey
girl
whoa I don't have room for this oh I yes
I do you keep saying that and you keep
having her I must I did I don't know if
you want to sound a little regulator
cool I don't mean to do that is every
time every time
these beads I understand anything all
right well I don't see anything else I'm
allowed to do in here besides hang out
Jesus goodbye Jesus so I'm gonna send
the green up to him yes how does that
sound to you
sounds good oh that's the fishtank I was
like there's just someone like humming
in here
he's just sitting in the room going I'm
very
what is it sensitive to noises they said
carts but it's all [ __ ] hearing
everybody is all right no you haven't
changed it all let the record state
you're still a D I haven't been in here
oh it's red I'm just gonna scope it out
there's the device for entering the
combination but it's missing a part and
can't be used so I need the part and
then I need the numbers which I think we
wrote down embracing a what a demon oh
yeah they do a good job putting a lot of
like really creepy paintings in here
don't they
yeah so to the dumbwaiter
right here's the green machine do you
think I should also give him a gun
because he does not have a gun I know
but it's fine he doesn't have any mold
tops either they're in the other room
maybe a gun might help I don't know I
feel like it would
jinke like kisses in there and then
shuts it so that she gets a clean
probably yeah baby son of a handgun okay
he's been doing some reverse flies the
back edge of his delts or [ __ ]
shredded as long as you're embracing
other men's sexiness I'm cool with it
2018 is the year of the objectification
of men
it's almost over I feel like it barely
began my room for this gun
we'll get your compliments in before
December hurry up you gotta like compare
them to something like you got a look at
a guy and be like wow what a nice piece
of bacon that guy is yeah what a nice
what a nice piece of chicken thigh
mmm-hmm there you go what a knife what
check out his pastrami yeah ooh I like
that I'm gonna take I'm gonna use it up
you like that girls check out his beef
patty that's nice you you're good at
this yeah oh yeah I am you've had a lot
of experience
all right so sorry he's got a gun and
he's got a full heel should he go in
there again yes he does have a gun you
thought you probably clipping a gun
there's no crazy oh right I don't have
any mall tops
you don't need maltose but I don't even
think there's anything worth the shotgun
there either
no monkeys no monkeys mother the money
to monkeys
oh I hear it what am i shooting you know
walk I think it's a zombie on the ground
no you might as well just crunch him
what a dumb noise he makes that dude
might not be dead - you're right little
piece of [ __ ] I saw it in the wall day
[ __ ] get him kill him stop his face off
am i doing this right
I think so he's playing dead very well
though commitment well cool wow that did
go whoa just making sure it's yeah miss
anything
what is that it's that more gas
sterilizing agent yeah probably gasps OH
oh [ __ ] I think he's full [ __ ] I
shouldn't what should I do
those bullets are pretty valuable drop
for now just drop the shotgun shells our
first dates right here why only you drop
one cuz you're gonna you're about to use
this devising agent I guess right now
yes sooner so it's you're using on that
gas I think right
I feel bad leaving shotgun shells in
here that's it right there's no like
secrets in these walls yeah all right I
know cuz we're getting towards me in the
episode and we're about to be
sterilizing you so I'll write down
something oh my god that shadow scared
me
shotgun shells in the morgue put that
post-it note like on the monitor so that
everybody who works here sees that
there's shotgun shells in the morgue
sorry what am i doing people in the
comments please just flood the comments
by saying shotgun shells and shotgun
shells in the morgue actually that
reminds me I want to get to a couple
more comments before we finish we'll
tell me what I'm supposed to be doing
I'll go back to that guess the circular
gasp room on the map
you don't need Rebecca and you're gonna
put that sterilizing agent in it it's to
the right I've had terrible Henry
shotgun shells in the morgue that would
be such a sweet song so
okay Nathan Shepard says a death wipe
will add to the death tally but not a
restart marry half of your deaths have
actually been death wipes Wow
the episode low last time was trying to
equip bullets episode high was -
definitely pushing the boxes a shame you
only had the chance to do this three
times
oh the post-it note wait wait wait wait
you're fine
I was it ready I'm gonna get [ __ ] bit
oh there's another one in there I know
all right they're done those [ __ ]
dumb I like was totally unprepared for
this Oh a breeding key where does that
go
that's what it takes that's Hawaii
that's why it's never happened
aha it's been sitting here finally gonna
become a man waiting okay we could
probably I think this is a good place to
end yeah we're probably save we're all
you both could save you're both near
typewriters um does anyone have a oh
she's more ideal do you think he's safe
in here though
[Music]
you might as well send her the breeding
room key okay
I think oh no no that and keep that so
we know what to do we're gonna do the
next one um I can give it to her you
just hang out with it yeah but you might
as well just save with him since you're
up here oh you want me to save with him
either one yeah cuz I went the wrong way
that's fine just stay with her then just
switch to her and then save okay I'll
put him by the dumbwaiter that will
remind us okay
also there's shotgun shells there's
shotgun shells in the mark well you go
get him now but I kind of like no this
supposed to know it's sitting in the
stream room for a week a shotgun [ __ ]
there's an exclamation mark on it
for anyone who's I can't see it it's
just
oh man it's way back there I'll be right
back
[Music]
I feel like you've done a good job it's
not gonna focus but you can make it
focus you know I did it when I showed
that photo of you peeing your pants
Ava Cassandra I'm gonna ignore that Ava
Cassandra said lifting his cosplay as
Mary is so uncanny who reversed the
scroll on this all right we go back to
the intro screen bear with me for a
second so sweet
we'll be back next week as always thanks
for bearing with us while we took that
last week off mm-hmm
I don't know are you you're probably
gonna stop by for our extra life at some
point people are asking if we're gonna
play anything I have no idea if we'll do
like Knievel stuff I know like Jean Luc
was planning it has like a schedule for
other stuff so I can't promise we'll do
anything then but it would be cool but
it's totally up to you guys doing your
awesome extra life stuff when is that
November 9th or 7th whatever that
weekend is but yeah we'll be back next
week on Saturday for now I have a good
rest of the weekend everybody and we'll
see you then hey I didn't die I did not
I did not die yeah I don't know